we're all mortal
when and how do you think Elon will
retire from the insanely productive
schedule he's on now
I would think that he would hate to
retire I think that he can't live
without the pressure the drama
they all land feeling
um
it's never
been anything that seemed to have
crossed his mind he's never said maybe I
love Larry Ellison's house on the beach
in Hawaii maybe I should spend time in
doing instead he says things like I
learned early on that vacations will
kill you
uh he gets malaria when he goes on one
big I mean he goes on vacation at one
point and they oust him from PayPal and
then he goes to Africa one boy he gets
malaria he says I've learned vacations
kill you lesson learned well it's
interesting because the projects are
100 plus year projects one of the weird
things
is watching him think
incredibly long term
one of the meetings every week
early on when I was
watching him was Mars colonizer and we
did to a two-hour meeting about what
would the governance structure be on
Mars
what would people wear how would the
robots work and
would there be democracy or should there
be
a different form of
governance
I'm sitting there saying what are they
doing what are they talking about I'm
not trying to build rocket ships and
everything else they are worrying about
the governance structure of Mars and
likewise
whenever he's in a tense Moment Like
There's a Rocket's about to be launched
he'll start asking people or something
the way future like the new
uh leaked engine or something if we're
going to build that do we have enough
materials ready to order or
I don't know he'll just ask questions
like when he's building Robo taxi the
global car the twenty five thousand
dollar inexpensive Global car that's not
a total passion he was talked into doing
that his passion is Robo taxis but his
passion is how are we going to make this
Factory to do a million cars a year so
even the robo taxi is a longer range
Vision I mean he's been touting it since
2016. but you know we're not I don't
know Robo taxis I mean there's waymo may
be doing a little experiment but there's
not cars being manufactured without
steering wheels that are going to take
over the highways
yet so he's always looking way into the
future as my point I just hope that um
there's a lot of Da Vinci's and Steve
Jobs's and Einsteins and Elon musk's
that carry the the flame forward that's
one of the reasons you write books about
these people is so that if you're a
young woman in a school where you're not
being told to do science and you read
the code breaker about Jennifer doudna
you say okay I can be that and when you
say oh maybe I'll be a regulator or you
say oh no maybe I'll be the person who
pushes
the boundaries who pushes the lines who
pushes as Steve Jobs said the human race